[Music]
straight ahead
online crime daily it's a battle of the
experts as an iowa mother
accused of strangling her own daughter
with pajama pants
faces a second trial if you were ending
concluding what you're theorizing and
that's a circular argument
was little chloe's death a murder or an
accident
a judge makes a decision on whether to
release r
b singer r kelly from jail before trial
plus secret documents in the case
against alleged
sex trafficker gelane maxwell are
becoming public
and
we look further into body camera video
of a new york judge and his wife
fighting with the police law and crime
daily covers court cases from coast to
coast
[Music]
and welcome everybody to law and crime
daily i'm erin keller along with brian
buckmeyer and terry austin
trial has resumed for an iowa mother
accused of murdering her child
kelsey thomas chose to be retried by a
judge not a jury
after her first trial ended with a hung
jury authorities say she strangled her
daughter chloe with a pair of pajama
pants
thomas argues she confessed under police
pressure
and that her daughter's death was really
an accident
the defense called its first and only
witness a forensic pathologist who
disagreed with the state's finding that
little chloe
was murdered brian take us through this
testimony for us
yes aaron so the defense's expert said
he believed that chloe did not die by
manual strangulation
dr thomas young reviewed the autopsy
report conducted by the state
he says it's possible chloe got scratch
marks on her neck
from reaching up and trying to free
herself from the accidental
strangulation
he then demonstrated using chloe's own
pajama pants
what he calls a possible scenario from
how chloe died
there are a wide variety of situations
in which this can basically form a
three-quarter inch in diameter
transverse mark on the neck one of them
is to have it in this particular
situation
this is probably about 5 8 of an inch
which is a little bit less than three
quarters
but even having something like this
which is basically stretched out
and even maybe which may or may not have
been twisted in any ways
could have certainly made some kind of a
market as well
having the presence of seams is as well
where these are
items that are a little stiffer and that
they project
could also make certain kinds of marks
in the neck that would be
narrower um
so this particular kind of garment is
uh is capable of making those kinds of
marks on the child's neck
in my opinion state authorities believe
this was
murder but the defense expert says state
medical examiner's assessment is
in his own words problematic it relied
on the defendant's confession to come to
his conclusion
and the defense argues that confession
isn't sound
basically dr cavalier
says that this is a strangulation and
then law enforcement investigators
basically say bring up the element of
strangulation
into the whole thing into the mix
and then basically continue at it until
basically she agrees with dr cavalier's
findings
that's essentially accepting
what you are what the premise is as a
conclusion it's a circular argument
dr cavalier by calling this a
strangulation
off the bat essentially contaminates a
second
interview here with the uh the person
introducing the element of strangulation
into the whole mix
when such a thing was not even
spontaneously
offered by any witness
doctor young also testified at thomas's
first trial
his testimony this time around was
consistent
brian let's head down to terry austin
with the prosecution cross
examination of this witness terry
actually the state came out strong by
having the doctor
admit he's never conducted an autopsy of
a child strangulation
prosecutors tried to poke holes in the
doctor's credibility
but young said this is his 500th time
testifying as an expert in a trial
would you agree that the fundamental
problem that you find with dr cavaliere
is that she's attempting to determine a
past event through an autopsy
yes you find that method unreliable
yes and it's unreliable for certainty
if you want to
deposit is the possibility to
investigate
you know holding that up is a hypothesis
that's legitimate but to state something
categorically and certainly on something
that is theoretical
is not reliable especially when it comes
to past events which are very
complicated
the defense indicated they would not be
calling any additional witnesses
and had one final question for the
defendant
ultimately you decided that you
did not want to provide testimony in
this case correct
and that was your choice that you made
freely intelligently
and without any threats or duress or
abortion from your defensive
direction yes
both sides rested their case transcripts
from witnesses
called during the first trial were
submitted to the judge
for her to consider their testimony
prosecutors and the defense
will submit their closing arguments in
writing by november 3rd
the judge will then issue her verdict at
her own discretion
so terry this same judge presided over
the defendant's first murder trial she's
reviewing most of the evidence as you
discussed
from the first case and then allowing
attorneys to submit those closing
arguments in writing do you think this
gives
each side enough of a fair shot to try
the case this time around
i do aaron because the judge is going to
remember
everything that happened in the first
case and even more importantly
it all comes down to the testimony of
the medical examiner
versus this forensic expert and i think
the judge is going to be able to
determine
which side she believes whether or not
this was
a strangulation as the prosecution is
trying to say or whether or not this was
just
a hanging as the defense is trying to
say he's basically saying
if there are no witnesses you cannot say
there was a strangulation so the judge
is going to determine that herself
so brian does this add up to reasonable
doubt that's the big question
did the defense evidence add up to
reasonable doubt if so there has to be
an acquittal what do you think
i would guess it does rise the level of
reasonable doubt because the only way
that the judge can vote otherwise
would be to say that the defense's
witness was not credible it doesn't
believe their testimony and has all the
credibility to the
to the prosecution's witness but if both
are credible and there are some level of
doubt and that doubt is reasonable
i think that's not guilty many questions
remaining in this case the judge has it
and will get
basically a decision on the judge's
timetable brian and terry appreciate the
insight
a judge has denied yet another attempt
by r b singer r kelly's attorneys to get
him out of jail
pending trial kelly's attorney used a
recent jailhouse attack to argue that
kelly was unsafe behind bars
and that he was a target in part because
he's famous
a federal judge sitting in chicago wrote
that kelly's attack was concerning but
does not warrant an immediate release
the judge also said that the isolated
incident
does not suggest that the federal bureau
of prisons is incapable
of safely housing r kelly and still
ahead here on law and crime daily a
judge makes a key ruling on court papers
which may help prosecutors convict the
ex-girlfriend
of pedophile jeffrey epstein and later
on in the broadcast one of the alleged
killers of a connecticut mother
is out of jail pending trial when we
return find out what's behind the
release of kent mcwinney in the alleged
killing
of jennifer doulos
a legal loss for jaslane maxwell the
ex-girlfriend of sex offender jeffrey
epstein a federal appeals court ruled
that a 418-page deposition maxwell gave
during a civil suit in 2016
can be released the miami herald sued to
get the documents which were part of a
civil suit filed by
against epstein rather by one of his
accusers virginia roberts duffray
the underlying case was settled in 2017
and epstein died by suicide in 2018.
maxwell is in jail pending trial on
charges she trafficked
young girls more than a year after a man
in dayton ohio was beaten to death with
a baseball bat and his body burned the
feds indict
five people for the crime an unsealed
indictment says
jose casey was abducted at gunpoint
last summer and beaten to death at a
home agents claimed the abductors made
ransom demands
casey's burn remains were later found in
a garage all five charged including
devin love and ryan reese are in custody
a security guard working for a tv
station in denver is
in jail charged with killing a man at
dueling
right wing and left wing protests in
that city
matthew dalla faces a second degree
murder charge police say dollop shot and
killed
lee keltner earlier this month after
keltner hit him
in the side of the face with his hand
and then sprayed him with pepper spray
dallas lawyer is quoted in local news
reports as saying the shooting was
self-defense a man in wichita kansas is
accused of threatening to kidnap the
mayor over the city's covet 19
mask ordinance the wichita police
department says
meredith doughty was arrested on a
charge of criminal threat
doty allegedly sent text messages saying
he was going to kidnap
mayor brandon whipple and slash his
throat because of the mask mandate
the mayor learned about the texts after
they were sent to another city official
in a video briefing the mayor called the
text horrendous
they read me the text messages that this
person was sending
to someone else who had access to me and
my
um and my address and they were looking
for my address so they could uh
susp uh i guess take part in
um executing a plan that would have
maybe resulted in harm in the end though
until i'm voted out or tell i am
actually successfully assassinated
like i will continue to be mayor i will
continue to do what i'm supposed to do
with updates with policy you know i will
not
stop and moving along now to the east
coast one of the men
accused of playing a role in the murder
of connecticut mother jennifer doulos is
out of jail on bond
attorney kent mawini is accused of
conspiracy to commit murder
his bail was reduced in part so he could
visit his ailing father in florida
mawini is fitted with an ankle monitor
so authorities can track his movements
he and michelle treconus are the only
two defendants left to face trial for
the presumed killing of jennifer doulos
after alleged co-conspirator photos
dulos the victim's husband
committed suicide earlier this year got
to ask about this brian
defendant's bond went from 2 million
down to 246 000 in cash
and property some of his parents
property being put up as collateral here
that seems like a huge reduction to me
is that
normal uh it is and it isn't it really
depends so the standard of changing bail
is a change of circumstances that
occurred from the last time
bail was set from what i understand the
change of circumstance is pretty big
that being that his father has uh cancer
that's migrated through his body all the
way into his spine i'm not sure how long
his father has or how bad the cancer is
but that's enough of a change of
circumstances to maybe reduce the bail
to allow him to see his ailing father
and of course if it's a serious uh
injury or ailment i mean it certainly
seems like uh there's some
mercy involved in the decision here so
terry we've got two defendants out on
bail michelle draconis is also out
and still no body yet for this poor
mother who's
been missing and presumed killed
you know it's not looking promising for
the family of jennifer doulos
time is passing and although there is an
incredible amount of circumstantial
evidence you know we have blood we have
zip ties we have video footage of
plastic bags being discarded
there still is no body and you know it's
difficult to really surmise
what happened when it happened and who
was involved
the state does have that evidence though
and they are pushing forward with the
two remaining cases out of the three
that they
originally filed and still to come here
on law and crime daily viral video from
the case of a new york judge caught on
body camera
shoving a police officer as another was
placing his wife in handcuffs
we dig further into what led to this
confrontation
right after the break
[Music]
we are digging more tonight into nearly
two hours of body camera video released
by the buffalo new york police
department the recordings show a judge's
wife arguing loudly with officers
and the judge himself shoving a
responding officer both the wife and the
judge wound up in handcuffs and
dropped a lot of names in government and
on the police force
in the process here's some of the fight
and some of the judge's reaction at one
point
you'll hear the judge drop the name of
buffalo mayor
byron brown who he calls a friend
ma'am if you don't stop yelling this is
going to be a problem for you
okay cool get over here
we are not doing this right now we are
not doing it
put your hands behind your back
i don't care i don't care i'm talking to
my daughter as a police officer
where does your daughter work for she's
in b district right i saw the seed
and listen i'm good friends with brian
brown he's like you're always something
our
storm i'm talking like this could punch
me in the face i'm getting a fan lip
i want to have my shirt wrapped like
this
he tore the shirt grabbing me
and ripped my necklace off okay okay
like like yeah like i'm fighting the guy
at one point an officer puts the judge
on the phone with a police
supervisor listen to this
it's gonna give me instructions to uh
this is detective constantino to
bring the phone over to you and let you
talk i believe it's on on speaker now
oh hey mark they're saying that you
pushed an officer you didn't
you wouldn't do that would you you know
what but he when he was
when he drank well he dragged maria when
the two girls around maria he was
dragging murray across the street and
actually was taking her down on my front
lawn
and i basically said listen just like
talk to her and i pushed him and i said
don't freaking tackle or i push them
i apologize to a mark right after that
because i said listen
i respect you guys in law enforcement
you know you know i go my daughter's a
police officer my son-in-law's police
officer all my family's police officers
i never mentioned byron brown's name
what we said was is that the guy across
the street
parks the vehicle which is a byron brown
owned vehicle like
like he blocks driveways and they did it
with all four cars tonight so
yes i was wrong by uh uh
telling the police officer i pushed him
and said listen don't tackle her like
that
i said you know show show talk to you
and you know i don't know what every
other neighbor said mark but trust me
like the i know that this has been going
on for like 10 years
mark listen i understand it i was in the
house when i was bringing the dog back
and i called 911 because the car
is blocking like a quarter of the
driveway apron
and that when i came out these girls
like they had maria in a chokehold
when we come back what led to the
confrontation neighbors who witnessed
the altercation provide new clues into
what went wrong
and who were defending themselves
against an alleged attack
the story picks up when we return
[Music]
we're back now with body camera video of
a new york judge shoving a police
officer and dropping names of
high-profile friends
the police never filed charges against
the judge or his wife
perhaps at least in part because several
neighbors told responding officers that
the judge
and his wife were being victimized
they wrestled they had maria chokehold
they went back and forth
okay i guess my my main concern in the
issue that i'm running into is
these are the people with clear injuries
so when i have injuries
yes when i come into this with i mean
not knowing all this like not knowing
which
i don't know anything about any injury i
don't know about any injuries
okay well no and that's why i'm telling
you like from my perspective what i've
got is
the people over here injured the people
are there intoxicated and that's why
they're in the back of the truck
it's hard to believe that they're in
cuffs and they're on their porch well
again this isn't a 20-year thing we're
here for the
immediate so okay i understood no i do i
appreciate your perspective i'm going to
just check with those neighbors as well
and see what we got
so that was one neighbor another
neighbor also said she saw the judge and
his wife being choked and attacked
and the judge and his wife trying to get
away here again is body camera video and
by the way this witness dropped that her
husband
was the city clerk somebody heard a lot
of yelling and screaming going on i was
actually thinking it was somewhere over
here i had no idea i just walked down my
driver and when i walked down
i saw them choking maria by her neck
choking her in the middle of the street
okay i yelled from my husband
city clerk buffalo to call 9-1-1
that those two fans was fucking
okay they tried to get away from them
and they did
to their driveway and then they once
again
attacked them in their own driveway okay
it was them decking down okay um
that that seems to track with a lot of
what we've been hearing yes
look at they've been okay and like i
told other neighbors the reason that the
other two were in the car right now is
because
we approached they were they're excited
well they
they were causing problems then we tried
to detain them they were coming at us
very aggressively that's why they're in
the cars
just explaining that but i do appreciate
having the kind of everything i
witnessed was
them attacking them okay and them trying
to get away from them
okay well i appreciate that um we'll
definitely take all that in
consideration
a senior advisor to new york governor
andrew cuomo responded to the situation
since the judge is a long-time political
ally who was appointed to the roughly
175 thousand dollar a year job by
governor cuomo
the adviser's comments read in part
court of claims judges are appointed for
a
fixed term and only if they are deemed
highly qualified by an independent
judicial screening committee
and confirmed by the state senate once
that happens they're part of a separate
branch of government
and disciplinary issues are under the
purview of the new york state commission
on judicial conduct so that's the view
from the executive branch here
about a friend of the governor so terry
got to ask this though
two sides to every story right it's
possible or i should say
is it possible that the judge was
totally in the clear for defending
himself and his wife
are they more sinned against than
sinning here based on what the neighbors
said
well the additional footage does show
more of the story but the bottom line
is even if he had been defending his
wife
he still assaulted a police officer and
there's no question that he received
special treatment and in fact they acted
as though they were privileged because
they knew
all of these individuals and they were
dropping names here's what i think at
the end of the day
anyone breaking the law regardless of
their race their economic status
their political influence should all be
treated the same and the question i have
is
did that happen here i think we all have
that question and that was perfectly
said terry so brian
you're a public defender do your clients
when they're in the back of squad cars
get
calls from detectives or supervisors
asking to clear up situations
be allowed to give additional versions
of stories and just have their word
believed
or even what do you mean word believe
aaron he incriminated himself
he said that he shoved an officer
i practice in new york you know what
that is that's penal law 121 18 that is
menacing
an officer putting them in reasonable
fear of physical injury that's a d-class
felony
no one gets that you know who definitely
didn't get that attica scott who was
arrested by a d
felony for protesting same situation
that's the brianna taylor case in
another state hey great discussion we
have to wrap up we'll see you next time
as we discuss justice in america
[Music]
hi i'm dan abrams in the exploding legal
and true crime genre
law and crime is the only network that
has it all
good evening and welcome this is a
complicated case don't
really jump to conclusions we break down
the case of a serial killer another day
of drama between both sides from
multiple live trials daily to original
and compelling programming
the law and crime network is everywhere
and we invite
you inside the jury box this
is law on crime
[Music]
you